So I'm going to start off with for
job in work dot jobs, which is giving me the jobs array in the work object.
Then I'm going to append HTMLworkStart to the work experience div,
which we can see right here in our HTML.
Then, I'm going to work on formatting the employer in the title.
To do so, I use the HTMLworkEmployer and
HTMLworkTitle strings that are in helper.js.
Calling the replace method on both of them,.
I will replace the placeholder data with our employer and
our title from the work.jobs object.
Notice here I'm using job, the iterator from the for
in loop, as the index of the job that we want inside the work.jobs object.
This variable, formatted employer title,
is a concatenation of formatted employer and formatted title.
We're just adding them together.
This last line here .appends the formatted employer title,
which we just created to .work-entry:last.
Now this is an interesting syntax.
In jQuery, we're selecting every object with a class work-entry.
We know we want a class because it has a dot in front of it.
But then, this colon last tells us that we specifically want to
append this formatted employer title to the last element
with the class work-entry on the page, which should be the one we just created.
Let's go ahead and check our work.
We've refreshed the page and we can see that within the work experience section,
we can see our two entries for
work experience for Planet Express and Panucci's Pizza.
>> And it looks good too